all right Astro Mike here is our first
question it is from Tim har Wellman
comes to us from Facebook
Tim says hmm what have you done with
Neil deGrasse Tyson and is it true that
you two are the same person
now I'm joking that's not what says it
all here's what it says he's from San
Antonio Texas where is Neil for PTSD oh
he's not here right now nah I don't do
anything to him you are the fine you are
the Neil deGrasse Tyson my friend okay
how accurate was the depiction uh
talking about the movie gravity which I
know you liked how accurate accurate was
the depiction of dead bodies in space
well you know we haven't had to deal
with that so I'm not really sure what
they would look like but I did think
about it Chuck and when I saw what
happened and I think it probably is
somewhat accurate even if you took
because you're at a vacuum if you took a
good shot and you were injured and you
were exposed to the vacuum I don't think
there'd be a lot of blood right I think
we're probably all kind of cauterize and
fries almost immediately right so I in
some ways although you don't want to
dwell on this when you think about what
would happen I think it kind of showed
that kind of what it might see so now
let me follow up with a with another
question very quick we don't want to
test that no no here's my own personal
question for that is there a NASA
protocol for bringing back one of your
comrades uh who is deceased in space so
you're on a mission yeah you know your
buddy dies you can is there a protocol
but not you know out of all the training
I had we never went over that one
so yeah so if we were we never went over
what we would do to dispose of how we
would what you know I think we would
probably improvise meaning that if
something happened in the spacesuit we'd
probably just keep them inside of the
space is it morbid that's probably what
we would do we'd probably keep them in
there so basically yeah that's kind of a
training for that is the movie we can
never you know what yeah yeah we never
you know there are certain things you
just don't want a sim you know it is
something they don't know we're not
gonna train that one right you know we
trained just about every other medical
procedure and everything you need to do
do you think that psychological do you
think the cycle I know it in my
be I think in my peach I think it's
something I don't want to simply we'd be
like you know what we're not going to
deal with that if something happens
we'll figure it out it we not we don't
need to we don't need to do that okay
oh no we never said you never had a
training excel out of all my training we
trained all kinds of morbid kind of
situations and bad emergency stuff that
hopefully whatever happened but never
being an undertaker in space we don't
train it so now here's here's some
question though right since there is no
protocol yeah do you think they would
bring the body back home kind of a la
Marines or launch it into space kind of
like Spock on Star Trek from a photon
torpedo Bay which one of my buddies yes
he's coming home coming home and it's
not negotiable so nobody gets left
behind
I would I would you know this is a
pretty you know I don't I wonder what we
really happened in that situation but my
my quick reaction is my buddy Paul my
buddy's coming home now would you want
somebody to bring you home or would you
want to be launched into space the place
that you love and one of the few human
beings who had an opportunity to be
there I would probably let my friends
decide that but if I it's not it's not a
question in my will necessarily for this
sort of thing but I would I would
probably want to come home to I think I
think it's more for the family I think
is what I'm thinking here it's a bit of
a morbid situation but I think you know
the family even having a body back to
have whatever service you would need
right I think we would we would want to
do that if we could well there you have
it Tim there it is there is no protocol
whatsoever so but the depiction of dead
bodies in space was pretty rad how do
you know you think about what would
happen if you got cut and you were
supposed to vacuum and what would happen
to you if you got exposed to vacuum air
you what you would look like and I would
try like a six year yeah you would
probably but it'd have to be very quick
because it you go fast man you don't
even know it you'd go fast all right
[Music]